hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play dream of the
Blood Moon now this is a game that
someone just sent me a link to honestly
I have no idea what the game is about I
just was a website with no information
on it just a download button I fired it
up and here we go it's on the Unreal
development kit so I have no idea this
could be great this could be fantastic
this could be horrible I I have no idea
Oh what hey I'm on my side sham steel
it's on the you Unreal development kit
so obviously it's gonna look pretty good
hello oh hi hurry oh oh who what hey you
leave her alone
yeah don't cry I'm here to protect you
maybe oh no I never know these four
games
I might not actually be here to protect
her I might be here to
Oh
okay huh all right so there's some weird
mysterious things that happen Oh uh-huh
you stay away from me lady oh my
goodness
holy crap uh okay
oh hey she's gone what the hell I'm in
some forest it's dark looks nice
okay Benny well it's not really dark
actually six tears six regrets five to
solve in one misplace bring them to my
tree I need to find six tears what
happened I was in a bed I was in a cozy
little bed just not two seconds ago and
suddenly I'm here oh my god I'm got hot
yes uh okay this kind of a path I'm not
exactly oh you shut up no don't start
with that okay this is a funky tree here
up all right III don't even know okay
I'm I'm kinda just running through the
woods now knowing that that thing is
chasing me holy hell is this Hey well I
run too much I cough what that oh hello
oh I'll try not a good sign I got a
candle get away from me lady ah no I
can't print crash a good god I mean
seriously
holy hell get away from me lady I see
you just shapes and shimmering in the
background which is really cool touch
but I don't know where I'm going or what
I'm doing or why I'm doing it or you
know I don't know anything about what
I'm doing right now is insane though I
mean wow wow wow easily indeed yeah I
have no objective so I really don't know
if I'm doing good or not I mean besides
the tears thing I really don't know what
what the dealio is that's really cool
that looks really cool I like that I
like that
I mean the graphics in this game oh hey
hang on there's a path here again let's
see if I'm just gonna follow the path it
might be like I don't know slender's
woods or something like that where I got
a follow I don't know how that lady game
found me so quickly before I seem to be
doing a little better now uh bridge okay
all right then hello anybody home is
anybody there
anybody anybody at all i Crampton them
uh uh I'll go this way come on give me
some give me something give me something
give me something give me something hey
what's this overturn cask nothing to
click on wagons all broked nothing I
don't see I'd see anything useful here
it's just um yeah I don't see anything
it's nothing right the trail continues
yes I'll find out I mean once you get
used to it you're kind of just walking
in the woods waiting for whoa hello uh
uh whoa
I can't go that way it's an invisible
wall huh oh you know the invisible walls
these weird moving shadows and clouds of
fog there I really like the effects in
this game but I don't know
none I feel like I'm missing out on
something like I was supposed to do
something early on and I I've kind of
overlooked it I'm not sure exactly who
you know after that after seeing that
lady first I am kind of I'm kind of okay
with just wandering through the woods
yeah I don't need anything else no I
think I'm just reaching the edges of it
actually this is kind of very similar to
my first playthrough of slender when I
had no idea the layout of the wood I
imagine you need to get a better
understanding of how this woods how
these woods are set up but what ah ah hi
what now hi we're done hi what the hell
I did ah ah oh thank god darker things
got darker oh god okay I'm fired you go
going going
oh go away what is this is this kaveh a
canyon
what is this okay
who I saw that ah no go away Lulu get
away you [ __ ] get away Qi stay away oh
you stay away or you stay the F away
there's got to be something in these
canyons it's like whenever I look behind
me everything gets really shadowed it's
like the Sun is now shadows now oh is
this what is this what is you what is
you ah whenever I turn backwards it's
literally like just a blot out it the
Sun just gets blotted out
oh man oh man there's got to be
something here right it's right it's
gotta be gotta be maybe not ha ha I
can't tell if I'm a guy or a girl oh man
I tell you this came oh I don't know
what to make of it I can't see when I
look in that direction I can't even see
I can't see okay I'm just gonna walk in
the direction that I can see I didn't
find anything in those pillars so I'm
gonna assume that there wasn't anything
maybe there was I I really don't know
Oh God suck it up guy girl girl guy I'm
not sure I'm a pretty little girl all
right I might have tried I'll wait I see
something in the distance there I'm
gonna try to give this as full of
playthrough as I can
wait this is where I was was it I was I
here isn't this where I started or
something huh I don't know maybe ah ah
fudge ah ah the oldest trick in the book
oh hello what the Oh ah
hiding here again I can hear them
searching me escaping punishment okay
man lady uh-oh
why am i following her why am i
following her oh I don't know I don't
know I don't know haha burritos open now
go away oh I have been slain ha ha ha
what what what oh no I don't know what
the hell happened
ha ha ha that was an awesome game I'll
admit that and I haven't beaten it yet
but uh yeah guys go try this out for
yourself I can't believe I didn't hear
about this sooner unless it's like a new
release I don't know but uh links in the
description below if you want to try
it's a big download but Holly holy hell
that was worth it and man oh man that is
a great game amen okay so thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
ah back the address [ __ ] you
I can't